modern society I think has destroyed the
human human psyche in a lot of ways we
should be working non-stop like but the
problem is for whatever reason I never
understood this there are people who are
like I don't want to work I want to do
nothing it's like hold on if your
argument is you want to work on
something specific and not the thing
you're working on that I get yeah you're
like hey I'm a restaurant manager but I
really want to be a software engineer so
I'm going taking night classes to learn
how to code and then I'm going to go and
work for a firm that I get that's like
I'm not working where I want to be but a
lot of these people want to do nothing
they they they're just like I shouldn't
have to work I should be able to just
lay there and and and consume resources
from other people and a lot of those
people who do they actually like the
what like to what you said your mindset
you would see it as a net positive to be
able to have something to work on after
your day job because you're passionate
about it they find it almost as an
affront to them that they would have to
have a day job to then work on the thing
that they want to